welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is David Cameron a professor of
political science at Yale and the
director of the European Union Studies
program at the Macmillan Center he joins
us today to discuss the ongoing eurozone
debt crisis which began three years ago
shortly after a newly elected government
in Greece announced that the budget
deficit would be much larger than the
previous government had predicted in May
of 2010 after Greece found it was unable
to issue new debt to cover maturing debt
and its deficit it requested assistance
from the EU and the IMF and received a
three-year loan of 110 billion euros yet
two and a half years later Greece still
needs assistance and last week the
parliament approved another round of
deficit reduction measures in order to
receive the first installment of a
second bailout this one of 130 billion
hero's welcome professor Cameron thank
you so tell me why does Greece need the
second bailout well Greece needs a
second bailout because the first one of
110 billion wasn't enough their deficit
turned out to be much larger than they
had anticipated because in 2010 they
introduced a an austerity budget cutting
the deficit cutting spending raising
taxes that made the economic contraction
worse therefore they had to do that
again and they had to do it a couple of
more times and by the Spring of 2011 it
was clear that they would need another
170 billion or so of help 40 billion of
which might be the remainder of the
initial bailout
that meant they would need another 130
billion or so that was decided a year
and a half ago and we are still now
going through the negotiations over the
second bailout so it is not yet
completed Greece hasn't yet received the
first tron Shore a slice of the second
bailout it's been going on for almost 18
months this protracted negotiation in
part because the second bailout required
the private sector bondholders to take a
substantial haircut okay reduction in
the face value of their bonds and the
so-called troika the EU the ECB the
European Central Bank and the IMF had to
agree that Greece had met the terms of
the second bailout okay and they aren't
quite there yet and Greece is running
out of money okay what over the past
three years Greece has had to do a
certain a number of things deficit
reduction things what has been the
fallout from that politically
economically well the fallout has
they've concentrated on cutting spending
there's been a recurring problem that
Greece doesn't have enough tax revenues
and there's been enormous tax evasion
that's an issue now they are in the the
public is not paying their taxes people
have been taking euros out of the
country if they could because they
feared that Greece might have to leave
the eurozone and introduce a new
currency its own currency that would
depreciate in value so people holding
euros in Greece fled if they could so
tremendous amount of money has gone the
pressure has been primarily on cutting
spending and as a result the economy has
contracted further and meaning the GDP
has dropped substantially more than
was estimated initially the unemployment
rate has now gone up over twenty-five
percent wow those under the age of 25
have an unemployment rate over fifty
percent and there's enormous pressure on
pensions on the elderly on health care
and end on the private sector so it's
it's a huge and recurring problem
meanwhile the debt that Greece has now
has continued to increase as a share of
GDP so it's now approaching 180 190
percent of GDP and there's a likelihood
it will need another additional haircut
for the bondholders many of whom now our
official bondholders lenders okay so
this has been going on for for a while
now three years minimally what why has
it been so difficult to deal with this
Greek crisis and do you see any light at
the end of the tunnel so to speak yeah
it's it's an interesting problem because
Greece isn't the only country that has
had to get assistance latvia had to back
in 2008 ireland in 2010 portugal in 2011
and the spanish banks need assistance
now and Cyprus is about to get alone as
well but putting aside Cyprus of all of
those by far the most difficult case has
been greased and I think to tell the
truth it's a combination of the fact
that the problems have existed from the
outset Greece had one hundred percent of
GDP a debt GDP ratio of one hundred
percent when it came in when it was
admitted initially in 2001 it had a
deficit way over
of the three percent limit that the EU
has for eurozone state from the otts
from the onset and were they working
with them from the onset to try and deal
with that issue or they just well they
were but one of the problems is the
eurozone there are many problems in the
eurozone and why this crisis came up but
one of the problems was the fact that
the eurozone has no real ability to
limit budget deficits and the debt of
the member states they can warn them
about it they can issue stern
declarations that they have an excess of
deficit but they have no effective
sanctions okay and they have no
effective ability to limit that as a
result Greece has been a very difficult
debtor you might say it's had very
difficult political problems in reaching
agreements on all of the austerity
budgets that the eurozone and the IMF
have required of compare that with
Ireland for example which has gone
through the same process and is now
although it still has a high level of
unemployment it's still doing it is
doing much better and so why is Ireland
doing so much better yet Greece is still
struggle Ireland basically I hate to
sound use a trite cliche but Ireland has
taken its medicine it figured out it
realized what it had to do and it did it
quickly and it did it early and what did
what did it have to do well among other
things that recapitalised its banks it
reorganized and recapitalised its banks
immediately that's something that is
still a lagging problem for Greece and
it's a problem for other countries as
well such as Spain and it took the
bitter pill of austerity which
means reductions in wages and reductions
in spending so you do get a severe
economic contraction another example
would be the three Baltic States which
went through a depression sized economic
contraction in two thousand eight and
nine and kept their currencies pegged to
the euro throughout took a very
difficult economic contraction and have
now pulled out and actually have
relatively high rates of growth and
they're generating new jobs and they're
doing better Greece has never really
gone to that point it's resisted each
step of the way and it's partly
inability to political to have to carry
out the political obligations that they
make when they negotiate these bailouts
it's a problem of administrative
competence of the government I think
it's a it's a it's a you might say
Greece is a deviant case to some extent
in these in this crisis okay given that
then do you see a way out for Greece a
light at the end of the tunnel anything
well I think there will be eventually a
recovery but just to give you an example
there is now an argument going on
between the IMF and the eurozone over
whether Greece will get its debt to GDP
ratio back down to one hundred and
twenty percent by 2020 oh my dear IMF it
says it has to the eurozone is now
saying well it probably won't I think
the conversation that's going on now is
focused on the fact that sooner or later
Greece will have to write off a
substantial additional portion of its
debt and that'll mean that other
eurozone countries the official lenders
will take
losses right but there's really no way
out other than ultimately writing off
some of that debt because I think most
people realize it's unsustainable so
wouldn't it be better to write that debt
off sooner rather than later it would be
it would be many people think it would
have been smart to have done that early
and but that's very difficult of course
politically do but okay so as you look
back over the past three years what do
you think are the most important reasons
that this crisis occurred and what can
what could have been done that's that's
not what can be done that isn't already
being done to prevent it happening again
well I think there are a number of
reasons one reason this crisis happened
is that it the commitment to emu was a
political commitment it wasn't and it
wasn't based on economic criteria and
while there were economic criteria the
countries had to satisfy in order to get
into the eurozone low interest rate low
deficit so forth in fact those criteria
were loosely applied some of the
countries that didn't meet the criteria
were nevertheless led in and the
criteria didn't have anything to do with
competitiveness with the ability of a
country to compete in the European
single internal market without resorting
to a devaluation a second problem was
what I mentioned earlier they had no
effective and still have no strong
effective sanctions for excessive
deficits excessive debt excessive
structural imbalances a third factor
that's important it seems to me is that
they have no means yet of regulating the
financial flows that occur
of banks borrowing and lending and one
of the consequences of going to the
single currency which meant among other
things a single monetary policy run by
the European Central Bank and a single
central bank controlled interest rate
was that interest rates plummeted in the
countries that used to have very high
interest rates pre euro most notably
Greece Italy Spain Portugal southern
Europe that meant that it was much
cheaper to borrow and so there was a
tremendous increase in borrowing and
much of that borrowing came from other
European banks and there was a
tremendous flow of money into the south
from northern banks and from the banks
in the south as well for development
projects real estate housing
construction so forth all of which was
completely unregulated and we now have a
situation where there's a huge amount of
money sitting in the banks the banks are
owed by borrowers who cannot repay the
loans and those banks can't repay the
banks from which they borrowed money all
of that is a long-winded way of saying
one thing that EMU didn't do was it
didn't create a banking Union didn't
create a single regulatory mechanism to
oversee financial flows borrowing and
lending within the eurozone do you think
that's something that they will consider
doing moving towards well they are
committed now they now they now realize
they have to do that and they have
actually committed to creating what they
call a single supervisory mechanism for
the financial institutions by the end of
this year and have it operational as of
next year and once that's in place
then there may be a way to recapitalize
the banks in Spain and elsewhere that
need need assistance because essentially
many of the loans that they have are non
performing and will never be paid off
right right you have argued that the
eurozone will remain intact while others
have said it probably will disintegrate
do you still believe that it will stay
together or do you believe our given the
situation that we see today do you think
it it is possible for it to say together
yes I think I think it will stay
together I've made that argument in
print and I've made it actually before
Mario Draghi this summer that the
president of the european central bank
said the central bank will do whatever
it takes to keep the eurozone going and
and I have made that argument for a
simple reason the European states are
highly dependent on trade with each
other the probably the single most
important treaty in the history of the
European Union was the Treaty of Rome
that created a single internal market
free movement of goods services capital
people as the result of that the trade
the dependence of or the extent to which
countries dependent on exports increased
over time but what increased in
particular where their exports to other
members of the European Union so the
countries are highly dependent on that
trade just to give you an example
Germany exports for Germany constitute
fifty percent of its gdp that's much
more than in the US and sixty percent of
those exports go to other EU states
which means that thirty percent of its
gdp comes from exports to other EU
countries and that's true of all of the
European states now
imagine if we in the US had 50 different
central banks and 50 different
currencies with our economies as highly
integrated and interdependent as they
are sooner or later someone would say
what we need is a single central bank
and a single currency much simpler and
it reduces all kinds of transaction
costs and impediments to trade and the
movement of goods and services and so
forth so I think that's a fundamental
structural imperative that actually led
the EU to propose back when I was in the
EC the European community back in the
late 60s and 70s proposed the creation
of EMU so I think there is a very strong
impulse to move forward the problem
though is that they created a monetary
union but they didn't create an economic
Union we have EMU without the e economic
and monetary union but we don't have the
economic Union but what do you mean by
that well I mean a high degree of
coordination of economic policies so
that the states are cooperating in
setting their macroeconomic targets so
they're all working on the same page so
to speak yeah and in terms of fiscal
policy it means some degree of
collective authority over the budgets
over the fiscal policies of the Member
States a fiscal union is a phrase that
has been used very widely recently and
they are moving very slowly toward that
so that you could imagine an economic
and monetary union would include not
only a monetary union but a banking
union of fiscal union and economic union
and they're trying to create all of that
but they're doing it on the fly you
might say in an ad hoc post hoc way
responding to the crisis and in some
sense it reflects the shortcomings
in the initial design you might say
design flaws of EMU as it now exists and
they recognize that and they're moving
toward it and in fact we'll be talking
about that in the next european council
meetings but when will those be well
there'll be a meeting actually there's
one next week and then there's one in
december the european council of the
heads of state and government of the
member states and they are looking at
the possibility of a treaty at some
point in the future that would move them
some distance closer to that goal but
it's still a goal in the future how far
in the future do you think a long way in
the factor and a long way in the future
in part because a treaty requires
ratification by all of the Member States
and while and that means a public
support in some cases there are some
countries that would many countries
actually that would reveal they had to
have a referendum on a treaty that was
actually creating say a quote genuine
EMU which is what is now being discussed
in the European Council and we've had
previous treaties that have been
defeated in referendums the public has
lost a great deal of trust in the EU as
a result of this crisis and there are
further complications as well for
example the German Constitutional Court
would have to approve any treaty and it
has been of all the actors in this
crisis the one that has most
consistently argued for protecting
democratic rule but in the states as
they move toward greater supranational
control over economic fiscal monetary
policy
and how do you create a fiscal Union a
banking Union and economic union moving
those powers to the European level and
still have fully democratic states
controlling their budgets can doing what
parliaments do it seems impossible
that's a real challenge and it's
something that the Constitutional Court
is very worried about right well more to
come clear away so thank you for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work around this ongoing crisis
okay thank you you're welcome for more
information about professor Cameron and
his research please visit our website at
yale edu slash mcmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale